welcome back to drew's news well now
it's time for a pic from drew's little
yellow book
and today i've got a secret weapon
what is this it's a spaghetti measurer
that's right
this is one person
just gonna say that is not how i do it
i'm like to me this is one person right
that's a serving oh so the little hole
that's a a single serving i'm trying to
this okay so all right this would be uh
a two person and then that's a one two
and and three and four or as i like to
say one two three and four
um anyway it measures you know a healthy
amount of pasta perfectly portioned out
for the amount of people that's eating
if that's goals
good
i'm i'm going one hole up all right
um also uh don't forget to check out um
our on the go show with our podcast
every weekday you'll get a full episode
of our podcast in your ears and you can
just stream it wherever you get podcasts
i have to say i really um love uh the
news for podcast too so you can get some
interesting stories and you know takes
on people who are snoring
[Music]